اعلى وقع الاشتباكات الهدنه تقترب من
نهايتها في السودان
متحور جديد لكورونا يثير الرعب وينذر
بعوده الكمامات ماسك يعتزم فرض رسوم على
قراءه المقالات على تويتر
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه من الملف الاسخن وهو السودان فعلى
وقع تواصل الاشتباكات تنتهي ليل اليوم
هدنه الايام الثلاثه المعلنه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع لوقف القتال الذي دخل
اصبعه الثالث متحدث باسم الجيش السوداني
اكد للعربيه ان القوات المسلحه تقوم
بعمليات تمشيط واسعه في بحر وجنوب ام
درمان مشددا على ان الجيش يهدف الى طرد
قوات الدعم السريع من المناطق السكنيه
بدورها اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع ان الجيش
لا يزال ينتهك الهدنه واوضحت في بيان انها
تعرضت لهجمات بالمدافع والطائرات في مناطق
متعدده بالخرطوم
متحور جديد يعود بفيروس كورونا الذي اوشك
العالم على نسيانه الى الواجهه فالحديث عن
الاجراءات الاحترازيه عاد مجددا بعد
الانتشار المقلق
للمتحورس خبراء الصحه في بريطانيا راوا ان
انتشار المتحور الجديد ربما يعني العوده
الى ارتداء الكمامات خاصه في الاماكن
العامه ووسائل النقل العام لوقف انتشار
المتحور الذي يصفه الخبراء بشديد العدوى
اما في استراليا فيثير المتحور الجديد
الكثير من القلق بسبب ارتفاع معدلات
انتشاره هناك فيما شدد رئيس فريق اللقاحات
والتحصين بالصحه العالميه الى العوده
لفحوصات كورونا وارتداء الكمامات
جدل جديد اثار الملياردير او اثاره
الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك بعد
اعلانه عزمه استحصال مبلغ مادي من مستخدمي
تويتر لصالح وسائل الاعلاميه على المنصه
الزرقاء ماسك اعلن عن خطه تسمح لنا
الوسائل الاعلاميه بتقاضي بدل من
المستخدمين على اساس قراءه كل مقاله
لوحدها وبنقره واحده مضيفا ان هذا سيشكل
مكسبا رئيسيا للمؤسسات الاعلاميه والجمهور
معا ماسك اضاف ان الخطه ستبدا بالتطبيق
الشهر المقبل لكنه لم يعطي تفاصيل عن
الاسعار بشكل دقيق او النسبه التي
ستتقاضاها من الست تويتر
الى قصر في بريطانيا حيث قرر الملك تشارلز
ارتداء ملابس تعود لاكثر من 90 عاما خلال
حفل تتويجه ملكا لبريطانيا في مايو المقبل
ملابس الملك صنعت من الحرير الارجواني
وارتداها جورج السادس وهو جد تشارلز عند
تنصيبه ملكا عام 37 من القرن الماضي ومن
المقرر ان تتم مراسم التتويج في كنيسه
وستمانستر ابي بلندن بحضور رؤساء دول
وشخصيات مهمه وبحسب سحب بريطانيه فان
تكلفه الحفل ستكون اقل من حفل تتويج
الملكه الراحله الثانيه لكنه سيتضمن كافه
تقاليد التتويج التي تعود الى اكثر من الف
سنه
نختم مجازنه من فرنسا التي شهدت حادثه
سرقه محيره وقعت في وضح النهار اذا اقتحم
لصوص مسلحون متجر بلغاري للمجوهرات
الفاخره في ساحه فاندام الشهيره في وسط
باريس وسرقوا قطعا تقدر قيمتها بملايين
اليوروهات وفق ما ذكرته الشرطه والنيابه
العامه الفرنسيه اوضحت الشرطه ان ثلاثه
اشخاص وصلوا على دراجتين ناريتين دخلوا
المتجر في الحي السياحي الشهير وان اثنين
منهم كان يحملان بنادق مشيره الى انهما
اصاب حارس امن فيما تم فتح تحقيق لكشف
هويه اللصوص